brian another big story today that has a
lot of you talking nevada has paused the
johnson and johnson single dose vaccine
this after six
very rare blood clot cases among the six
point eight million doses
administered so far eight news now
reporter sally harmia was live outside
the convention center
a location that has given out that
johnson and johnson vaccine and sally
you got reaction from those who received
that vaccine right
denise despite the pause hundreds of
people still came out here to get their
first or second dose of pfizer
or moderna and they tell me they're not
being too concerned about
any side effects from any of them we had
researched all three
and my husband and i both decided on
johnson johnson jen marini got
vaccinated
a month ago she suffers from numerous
autoimmune issues
and after asking around she decided on
the johnson and johnson vaccine
the only side effects she had a headache
there's always going to be some people
with reactions
you have to expect that birth control
pills there you have more
chances of blood clots 19-year-old
justin flashner
got the johnson and johnson vaccine last
week at cashman center
i didn't hear it until my parents told
me about it
it's a little scary that it's having to
include people but i'm still
not hesitant or worried about it flash
nurse side effects
just chills science is not perfect
something's bound to happen at some
point to
some person it wasn't going to be all
sunshine and rainbows throughout the
whole thing there was going to be some
setbacks
mourinho's biggest fear now that this
news will prevent
others from getting a kova 19 vaccine
yes there's going to be some negatives
but
in the long term it's a really positive
thing for the entire country and
i still believe everyone should get the
vaccine
and out here live i do want to let you
know that this week hours will be
extended here at the convention center
tuesday through friday all the way until
that 7
30 p.m hour reporting live sally
jaramillo
8 news now